they arrived in the NFL four years apart
they had been starters their entire
careers now Andy Dalton backing up dak
Prescott in Dallas Jameis Winston the
number two to Drew Brees in New Orleans
and look that Prescott's never missed a
game so chances are Andy Dalton's not
even gonna play this year Jameis Winston
stepping in behind a guy who missed five
games last year with an injured thumb
who do we trust more if one of these two
guys is pressed into service dak
Prescott or ant not doc Prescott Andy
Dalton or Jameis Winston Peter come on
it's ant its Andy Dalton I mean it could
turn out five years from now that Jameis
Winston will be a consistent Pro Bowl
quarterback and we'll be looking back at
2020 as the year he finally learned
about how to play quarterback without
being a turnover machine when he played
for Sean Payton I don't know I can't
predict the future all I know is right
now I would rather have a reliable guy
who's gonna execute the game plan and be
a pretty accurate thrower and isn't an
interception machine so I'll take Andy
Dalton any day of the week again that
might change in two or three years we'll
see I mean I'm with you Peter
I mean yes I mean Andy Dalton first off
is you know underappreciated you know
under the radar better football player
than we all want to give him credit for
you know he lacks a little sex appeal
and things like that he's one of those
starting quarterbacks where if he's your
starter you always go he's good but
you're kind of looking out of the corner
of your eye for somebody maybe better to
be your starting quarterback I mean he's
gonna be an amazing backup quarterback
first off he is battle tested he's
played you know quarterback at a very
high level for a long time he played it
in a division that when when he started
his career was arguably the best
division in the NFL and the Bengals were
very relevant every year and stand-in
toe-to-toe with the Ravens and the
Pittsburgh Steelers so I'm with you but
I will say this Jameis Winston is a
big-time playmaker and Peter the point
you make about Sean Payton is real you
know I just I think Sean Payton is gonna
change Jameis Winston when Jameis
Winston starts to see whoa if I just
listen to this guy and I get all
these easy completions and I don't have
to risk it to get a biscuit because Sean
Payton's offense has lots of biscuits
with honey in and you know strawberry
jelly to go with it he's gonna realize
he can change the way he plays and
backup quarterbacks have thrived under
Sean Payton so you know I do think it'll
be a different I'm hoping for a
different Jameis Winston with it with an
expert like Sean Payton there's that
quarterback yeah see my choice is
Winston because he's with Payton if it
was flipped my choice would be Dalton if
he was when I hear you might that's the
bottom line
Peyton has he turned Teddy Bridgewater
into a guy who got 66 million dollars on
three years from the Carolina Panthers
and I think that's why Winston picked
the Saints and I think that's why I
trust him a little bit more just because
Sean Payton is that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports